Okay, so in this video I'm going to talk
about the idea of auction market theory.
So
most traders look at a chart and they
just see price kind of going up and
down. They [clears throat] draw some
support and resistance lines, use, you
know, Fibonacci, liquidity pools, ICT,
whatever it happens to be.
Um and some of this stuff works a little
bit.
Problem is it's not a framework or a
system by any means, but um it doesn't
tell you, you know, why price is doing
what it's doing and, you know, the
closest kind of complete answer to that
question it is auction market theory. So
it's not an indicator or a strategy. I
mean, I I have built the framework
around auction market theory,
um but it's the underlying logic of how
markets actually operate. So once you
understand this, um
everything else in the chart,
when you look at a chart, you know,
starts to make a lot more sense.
So to understand what auction market
theory is, kind of the first thing to
understand is why, or sorry, or what a
market actually is. And a market is just
an auction. So so all markets exist
simply to facilitate auction, and that's
really it. So it doesn't matter if
it's a market for selling used cars on
eBay or it's a gold chart or it's
Bitcoin chart or NQ, it doesn't matter
what it is.
They all operate the same.
Right?
Uh when when the market is open, buyers
and sellers are negotiating. Buyers are
trying to buy as low as possible and
sellers are trying to sell as high as
possible.
Uh that is what you'd call balance or
value. So this is kind of one analogy
that I like to explain it with.
Uh I'm going to draw this here. Let's do
something like this.
Okay, so let's use a car as an example.
Let's say Toyota Camry.
Okay.
And let's say a Toyota Camry is worth
30K. I don't actually know what they're
worth, but let's say somewhere around
there.
>> [sighs]
>> Okay, Toyota Camry, 30K, right around
the middle, that's what they sell for.
Some are sold at, you know, 31K.
Some sell at 29K down here, but more or
less, they sell around here. Let's say
this is a a you know, a Toyota
dealership.
And so most of them
just draw like this. Most of them are
sold here. So, each one of these is a
sailor. It's a Toyota Camry being sold,
right? So,
let's just say for simplicity's sake,
four sold here.
A couple are sold here closer to 31. A
couple are sold down here closer to
29.
Okay, so the most are sold around the
middle
um up towards the kind of upper extreme
31k. A couple are sold. Some are sold
down towards 29.
All right. And let's say that
you know, Toyotas become more valuable.
Something happens. They come out with a
new feature or new model and they're now
worth you know, there's some being sold
up here now.
Okay, let's say they're they're worth
35k up here, right? So, much more
expensive.
Let's say there's let's say 25k down
here.
All right. So, let's say that, you know,
there was manufacturing issues or
you know, whatever happened with Toyota.
Bad reputation. Something happened.
Um
So, now they're worth 25k. But, the
majority of them are being sold in this
kind of state here, this this area of
balance where between 31 and 29. This is
where Toyota Camrys are sold. And let's
say it's the upside here. Like I said,
new features come out or something like
that.
Um they add a new feature
and buyers are, you know, buying them up
here. A new model came out for a couple
years, let's say.
And something happens and buyers decide
that, okay, you know, Toyota Camrys are
no longer worth this much or they of a
feature. Let's say they add some new
trim package, whatever it happened to
be.
Um
So, they're no longer worth 35k. So,
they are likely to revert back to what
is called fair value. So, fair value is
where
both buyers and sellers are happy to
negotiate. So, like I said, at one
point, you know,
Camrys were worth 35k. They were, you
know, they were selling up here. There
there there was buyers that were happy
to
buy Camrys at this price.
Something happened in the market
and buyers are no
you know longer willing to buy Camrys
for 35K, right? So, where is it going to
revert back to? It's going to revert
back to what is fair value, right? Where
buyers and sellers were most happy to
you know, agree. They're in agreement.
So, buyers are happy to buy around 30K.
The dealers were happy to sell around
30K. So, now price goes back to, you
know, that 31 to 29K area
uh with the mean or most of them being
sold around 30K.
Okay?
Conversely, to the downside. Okay, so
let's say that something happened to
Toyota Camrys, right? They come up with
a new model and there's something wrong
with it. There was a callback, whatever
happens to be. Most of them are selling
for 25K.
And let's say that issue gets resolved,
right? So,
um
buyers are are very happy to participate
down here being that it's cheap, right?
But sellers are not, right? So, let's
say that the dealers, Toyota Camry
dealer,
um
now that this issue is resolved, they
don't want to sell down here because
it's not favorable for them. So, where
are they both happy to participate?
Well, back inside of this area where we
had a balance or, you know, like I said,
fair value. And fair value, like I said,
is where buyers and sellers agree. So,
then, you know, it would revert back to,
you know, more or less that 29 to 31K
area
with 30K being
uh the mean where the most
selling actually occurred, right? And
the most uh transactions actually
occurred, most time or volume was spent.
Right? So, what does this mean for you?
Well, we like to look at this on a
distribution or, you know, on a profile
basis. So, I'm going to talk about that
kind of in the next video, but more or
less it would give you a distribution.
So, I'm going to draw this here.
You can use a volume profile or a TPO
market profile which measures time. I'm
just going to briefly touch on this. You
get a distribution. So,
like I said, you have your
this was the zone kind of where we had
that uh
29 to 31k, 29 at the bottom, 31k up
here, 30k in the middle just for
simplicity's sake.
You know, most of the cars are being
sold around here.
Right? Um there's a little bit sold
around here, a little bit sold around
here. It reverted back into to value,
right? So, if you draw that kind of on
on a profile, right? So, you'd have you
know, a little bit of volume or a little
bit of trading happening around here, a
little bit of car selling around here.
Once you going to tap into that
31k area, you can see more cars are
being sold
towards the 30k where the most are sold,
you're going to have the you know, the
biggest
spike be being that, you know, this is
your Y-axis actually measuring
sales. And then, you know, your X-axis
would measure the you know, it would
measure how many um
cars are being sold at that level,
right? So,
right, there's your 30k and it starts to
slowly taper off towards 29. And then,
like I said, 25.
Right, this is where, you know, Toyota
had an issue. This is where Toyota was
doing great. Buyers weren't happy to
participate back here and then it
started to revert back in.
Okay, so the simple the simple takeaway
here is that the market exists to
facilitate auction and the market is
always seeking fair value.
Okay? So, what is fair value? It's where
buyers and sellers agree. It's fair.
It's it's it's not
too skewed in one direction. It's it's
not unfair for one side, but fair for
the other. Fair value is right in the
middle.
So, what does that mean for you? The
market is in really just two states. So,
the market operates in a balanced state
or it is in balance. So, when the market
is balanced, the market has found value.
So, a balanced market looks like this.
Probably very similar to you.
Range, consolidation, whatever you want
to call it.
And why is that value or why is that
balance? Well, it's balanced, right?
Buyers and sellers are both transacting
here. So, it's balanced.
Right, let's say that you know, there's
sellers here, there's buyers up here,
right? It remains in in a balanced
state. Buyers and sellers are both happy
to transact here until one side takes
initiative.
Once I take initiative,
that's what you call imbalance, right?
Upon a break or imbalance, whatever I'm
not going to use the car analogy for
this because I've already gone over it.
Upon a break leading to imbalance,
you know, the next thing you're going to
be looking for is,
you know, fair value. So, what is fair
value?
Well, it's where buyers and sellers, you
know, agreed.
So, if you think about this in kind of a
market context, is there only one
area of balance or one range on a chart?
No, there's there's plentiful, right?
So, let's say you know, maybe there's a
balance area here, there's another one
here.
Okay.
You know, maybe there's one over here
for a while.
Whatever [snorts] happens to be, right?
The market is always seeking fair value
and it often retests
areas of prior value. The market is that
that that's the simple
way that markets operate, okay? So, the
market will then come up and test this
older area of balance. If the market
decides that, you know, buyers and
sellers agree that this this is a fair
price,
the market will accept into that area of
balance being that they have decided
it's fair,
and it will attempt to traverse to the
other side of balance,
right? Once it reaches there,
it could do kind of one of two things.
It could continue to balance and buyers
and sellers continue to interact at that
level because they're happy to do so.
It could break to the upside
and you know, repeat the first process,
right? And then maybe you'd come up to
this area whether it accepts the price
and and and repeats this process, or it
rejects it and maybe it builds new
balance,
right?
Conversely,
let's say it doesn't do that. Let's say
it balances here, then it breaks to the
downside,
right? Often get a retest of that level.
It's going to revert back to another
area of prior balance being that it's
always seeking fair value. This is no
longer fair value because sellers took
initiative here.
Right? It broke down from this, so they
no no longer have Sorry, they've decided
that this is no longer fair.
They want to go elsewhere.
Right? So, it reverts back to prior
balance, okay, and it retests
balance. Like I said, if buyers and
sellers agree this is fair, you'll see
acceptance, which is a word we use
often,
acceptance back inside,
and you'll see a traversal, which is a
move from one side of balance to the
other.
Right? And then from there, that's your
full move through value.
Okay?
And then again, the process repeats
itself, so
is it going to balance here and build up
more value? Is it going to break to the
downside and seek lower? Is it going to
build out new value?
Is it going to balance and then break to
the upside and potentially come back to
older prior balance?
Right? It It's It's an endless cycle of
the market being in two states, balance,
imbalance, balance, imbalance.
And that's really it.
Okay, so what does that mean for you?
Right? At the end of the day,
the the you know, the edges of of value
or balance are support and resistance.
Whether you're inside of the area of
balance, you're outside the area of
balance, it's the simple fact that this
is the sole reason that markets
facilitate.
I'm sorry, the sole reason that markets
exist. They They exist to facilitate
auction. So, it doesn't matter whether
it's
cars on eBay, it's a gold chart, it's
Bitcoin, it's NQ. It doesn't matter,
they all work this way.
So,
um next video, I'm going to touch on,
you know, how you can actually use this
on a chart and how we like to understand
the idea of balance.